Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
¡Ahh! Perdón, bueno, esto no sirve más.
Pequeño fail, perdón, para empezar.
Quería hacer el ballet en hover
en el Colón, pero no.
Igual está bueno un fail, porque para
los que estén buscando en YouTube
videos de fails a las cuatro
de la mañana, como hacemos todos
(Risas)
–-bueno, como hacemos algunos--
este video va a aparecer ahí al costadito
y hay más chance de que
la gente vea esta charla.
El algoritmo va a jugar
en nuestro favor ahí en YouTube.
¿Todos sabemos lo que es el algoritmo?
Sabemos que existe, pero
¿qué es un algoritmo específicamente?
Estuve investigando un poco y lo bajé
a palabras que podamos entender.
Un algoritmo es un conjunto prescrito
de instrucciones o reglas
bien definidas, ordenadas y finitas
que permiten llevar a cabo una
actividad mediante pasos sucesivos
que no generen dudas a quien
debe hacer dicha actividad.
Aplicado a las redes, el algoritmo
tiene la instrucción de registrar
los contenidos que consumimos para
después ofrecernos contenidos similares.
El algoritmo sabe lo que nos gusta
y nos ofrece cosas que nos gustan.
Alto stalker.
El algoritmo sabe todo lo que queremos
y nos ofrece las cosas que queremos.
Entonces, aplicado a las redes
funciona así.
Y lo vemos claramente
en las plataformas de música.
Sabemos, por ejemplo,
que porque escuchaste R.E.M.
entonces recomendamos para ti Radiohead.
Entonces, porque escuchaste Radiohead
recomendamos para ti Adele.
Y porque escuchaste Adele
recomendamos para ti...
James Blunt.
Y porque escuchás James Blunt
recomendamos para ti...
antidepresivos.
(Risas)
No se sale de James Blunt
sin medicación, sépanlo.
(Risas)
Si estás en un momento James Blunt de
la vida, llamanos, sabemos qué hacer,
nosotros estuvimos ahí.
Si lo bajamos a tierra, el algoritmo
es como un mozo completamente sádico.
Un día vas al restaurant y te atiende
el algoritmo mozo y le decís:
"Me gustaría comer unos riñoncitos,
cortados finitos, doraditos".
Y él ya registra:
le gusta la carne de vaca,
le gustan las achuras, doraditos,
y va y te los trae.
Y al día siguiente pedís un matambrito
de cerdo, ¿puede ser doradito también?
Y registra de vuelta.
Come otras cosas que
no son vaca también, doradito...
Y vas un tercer día, y te dice:
"tengo algo para recomendarle".
Ya el algoritmo aprendió algo de nosotros.
"Tengo un pollito deshuesado
bien doradito que le va a encantar".
Vos decís:
"Buenísimo, me encanta, genial".
Y vas otro día y el algoritmo
está cebado y te dice:
"No me pida nada, ya sé qué ofrecerle.
Acá tiene, es próstata de mono,
doradita..."
Y decís, hay algo en la recomendación
que no estás terminando de entender.
Medio que a veces falla el algoritmo,
a veces un toque le pifia.
Además, lo que tiene de sádico
es que no para.
Me compré un aire acondicionado
hace un mes.
Hoy todavía tengo ofertas
de aire acondicionado.
En el mail, en Mercado Libre,
en Facebook, en Instagram,
en YouPorn, en todos lados
(Risas)
ofertas de aire acondicionado
(Aplausos)
Entonces, ¿cómo hacemos
para escapar del algoritmo?
¿Cómo hacemos que más gente
se entere que el algoritmo
nos ofrece más cosas que nos gustan?
Y que hay un montón
de contenidos para conocer
y de eso se trata TEDxRíodelaPlata.
De conocer un montón de cosas
que no conocíamos.
Acá somos 3000 personas,
más los que están viendo el streaming,
más los que vayan a buscar
esta charla, es mucha gente.
Pero nadie va a ver
esta charla del algoritmo
si no está buscando una charla
sobre el problema del algoritmo.
Entonces, ¿qué vamos a hacer?
Vamos a hackear el algoritmo, acá
en el Teatro Colón, y con esta charla.
No sería hackearlo, no vamos a entrar
por código, sería engañarlo un poco.
Engañarlo tampoco sería la palabra, sería
como inducirlo, bueno, tampoco es eso.
La verdad es que
lo vamos a tratar de cagar.
Estamos en la catedral de la
cultura argentina, de eso sabemos,
y lo vamos a tratar de hacer
con el algoritmo.
Pero ojo, porque como buen sádico
no es tonto el algoritmo.
Todo el mundo le mete etiquetas
a sus videos
pero si lo que está etiquetado
no es lo que hay en el video
el algoritmo no lo posiciona.
Así que nosotros sí lo vamos a lograr acá
viendo las cosas que la gente
quiere ver en YouTube.
¿Qué quiere ver la gente en YouTube?
Necesitamos tener youtubers en este video,
así le podemos poner
la etiqueta 'youtuber'.
No están arriba del escenario,
pero hoy en el Teatro Colón
está con nosotros
Hola soy Germán Garmendia,
acá está la foto del él.
También está Rubius. Morochius.
Están todos los youtubers.
Ya le podemos meter a esta charla
la etiqueta 'youtubers'.
HolaSoyGermán, Rubius, Morochius.
Alguien dijo gatos.
Con esto agarramos a medio mundo
en YouTube.
¿Están listos para un ahh?
¡Ahh, gatitos, no te lo puedo creer!
Son dos, dos gatitos, ¡me muero!
Mirá, ¡parece que saluda!
Le está tomando la fiebre,
¡no te puedo creer, parecen personas!
Ya tenemos gatitos en el video,
entonces ya podemos etiquetar.
Gatitos. Gatos. En inglés, kittens. Cute.
猫 en chino, ¿así se escribe gatos?
Es la misma forma en que se escribe
panchos, esa es una curiosidad.
Por eso es que ellos les entran.
(Risas)
I Love Gats.
¿Qué más tenemos que meterle a esta
charla para que el algoritmo la posicione?
Necesitamos hacer algo
para los chicos, un unboxing.
Los chicos se copan
con los unboxing, ¿vieron?
Se meten en YouTube a ver cómo otros
chicos abren regalos, abren juguetes.
Parece loco pero, si lo piensan,
nosotros también lo hacíamos,
pero no se llamaba unboxing.
Se llamaba "el cumpleaños
del compañero rico del curso".
(Risas)
Llegabas al cumpleaños y caía
el tío con una caja enorme
y era un Transformer que disparaba,
bailaba lambada, hacía todo.
Yo en un unboxing de mi cumpleaños saqué
el muñeco de Francella en Brigada Cola.
(Risas)
Que no hace nada, lo tenías que hacer vos.
Cinco minutos dura ese unboxing.
Así que vamos a hacer
un pequeño unboxing acá
para todos los niños que les encanta
abrir juguetes y ver qué viene.
Vamos a hacer un unboxing,
y ¿qué tenemos aquí?
¡Oh, es un balero!
¡Qué padre! (Risas)
Vamos a enseñar cómo jugar al balero.
Entonces metemos Tutorial también.
(Risas)
Y como son juegos...
Gaming, así que clavamos tres.
Entonces, para jugar al balero niños,
se juega de esta manera:
debemos asegurarnos de que
el cordel esté bien tiesecito.
Y tenemos que lograr que el bolón
encaje en el manchuque.
Entonces, ponemos el manchuque
en esta posición... ¡sí!
(Aplausos)
¡Bien, lo logramos! (Aplausos)
Hemos superado el nivel uno.
El nivel dos es igual
que el nivel uno. (Risas)
No tiene ninguna diferencia.
Bien, ya tenemos unboxing, metámosle
el hashtag de Unboxing.
¿Qué más necesita un buen video
para que se vea mucho en YouTube?
Yo busco mucho entre los rusos que están
re sarpados, ¿buscaron crazy Russians?
De repente, hay un ruso
y de acompañante lleva a un oso.
Y decís WTF, están re locos los Russians.
Bueno, Baryshnikov estuvo en este
teatro en 1998 y dejó gente,
se quedaban, no querían volver,
así que vení acércate ruso.
Él es ruso. Russian? Crazy Russian?
-- Re crazy. Te rompo todo el Colón.
¡No, no, eh, eh, tranquilo!
Otra cosa de crazy Russian más tranqui.
-- ¿Un golpe de Estado?
¡Qué sé yo! Por ahí es mucho. Mirá acá.
Tranquilo con los gatitos que están vivos.
Doble guiño para YouTube.
Crazy Russian con Gatitos suma.
Posiciona. ¿Un perrito?
Ay, un crazy Russian con perrito,
no te puedo creer ¡qué divino!
¡Tranquilo! (Aplausos)
Bien crazy Russian. Ya está. Gracias.
¿Qué más le hace falta a un video
para que se posicione en YouTube?
Un challenge.
Hoy vamos a hacer un challenge.
Ya les voy pidiendo
que subamos la luz de sala.
Porque todos vamos a participar
de un challenge.
Ninguno de los que conocemos.
No es el de tirarse agua en la cabeza.
-- ¡Muy buena, muy buena!
¿Qué pasa?
(Aplausos)
Bien, doble fail.
Vamos a hacer un challenge entre nosotros.
Le vamos a poner "Vanish Challenge".
¿Qué significa?
Yo voy a grabar dos vueltas
en video sobre mi eje.
Eso lo estudié, eje.
En la primera vuelta se va a ver
que el Colón está lleno de gente
que vino a ver TEDxRíodelaPlata.
Vamos a celebrar, vamos a festejar.
En la segunda vuelta
de este Vanish Challenge,
el challenge es que todos se escondan.
Entonces, para la segunda vuelta
tienen que estar todos abajo.
Si se tienen que tirar del gallinero,
tírense. (Risas)
La recomendación es que se metan
por debajo de los asientos.
La gente alta, haga un esfuerzo.
Los que tengan problemas de ciático,
métanle fuerte. (Risas)
Voy a dar dos vueltas.
En la primera digo:
"Qué bueno que es TEDxRíodelaPlata
con el Colón lleno, colmado".
Y en la segunda tienen
que desaparecer todos.
Podemos empezar un challenge.
Como el primer gil
que se tiró agua encima.
¿Saben lo que facturó ese? No. Nada.
Voy a empezar con el video.
¿Tenemos luz de sala?
¿Le podemos dar más luz a la sala
así los veo bien a todos?
Prendamos todas las velas, ¿son velas?
Voy a empezar a grabar,
a dar vuelta la cámara.
Ahí se ve bastante bien.
Voy con la primera, festejo.
La segunda, desaparecen.
Vamos.
Acá estamos en TEDxRíodelaPlata,
un Teatro Colón lleno. (Aplausos)
Parece un sueño, un sueño cumplido.
¡No puedo creer tanta gente mirando!
¿Dónde están?
Se fueron. ¿Fue un sueño nada más?
¡Funcionó bastante bien! (Aplausos)
¡Funcionó muy bien! (Aplausos)
Tengo para verlo solo en el celular
pero el arquitecto del Colón es tan genio
que pensó esto y si se fijan desde
el gallinero van a poder verlo también.
Miren, ahí quedó:
"Estamos en TEDxRíodelaPlata,
un Teatro Colón lleno, parece
un sueño, un sueño cumplido.
No puedo creer tanta gente,
tanta gente mirando".
"No hay nadie, ¿dónde están?"
Quedó bien. Bueno, hay un par que jugando
a la escondida perdían siempre, ¿no?
Pero bien, funcionó. Creo que esto
se puede viralizar tranquilamente.
Ya tenemos Challenge también.
Vamos a etiquetarle Challenge
a este video.
Y un video que se ve mucho en YouTube,
¿qué es lo primero que tiene?
Un fake, una imitación.
Eso es muy loco porque
no lo van a poder creer
pero incluso antes de que esta charla
termine ya está la copia.
Fíjense. Nos metemos
en este momento en YouTube.
Esto es ahora. Buscás:
Fail TEDxRíodelaPlata.
Temendo fail en TEDxRíodelaPlata.
El título que le pusimos recién.
Mirá. Está copiado igual.
La apertura de TED.
Lo hacen igual.
Mirá, entra con el hover.
Lo está copiando todo,
es exactamente igual.
Ahí se cae. (Risas)
No te puedo creer. Copian todo. Fail.
¡El balero! Está jugando al balero,
¡dejate de hinchar!
¿Qué más? El crazy Russian con el hacha.
¿Cómo sabían? ¡Es increíble!
Ahora con todo esto ya somos
un poco más conscientes
del problema del algoritmo.
¿Cuál es el problema?
Que nos muestra las cosas que nos gustan
y tenemos que tratar
de buscar cosas distintas,
cosas que el algoritmo no sabe,
que nos tiene que recomendar
para conocer un poco más.
Si quieren subir un video,
ya saben algunos truquitos para cagarlo.
Yo no uso anteojos en realidad,
pero a las charlas TED
las posicionan mejor
si el orador tiene anteojos.
(Risas)
Por eso los usé.
Así que gracias. Muy amables.
(Aplausos)